[Music]
tonight on BBC London news calls to ban
two Americans from an English Defense
League event in woolich over claims they
incite hatred against
Muslims it will give the oxygen of
publicity to two people whose views many
people Fil A horren we'll be speaking
live to the leader of the English
Defense League also
tonight an Essex firefighter is found
dead after a police investigation into
allegations of sex
abuse thousands of parking tickets are
issued by using unauthorized cameras but
the council says it won't be paying
drivers back
and is this the way to a happy working
life for bids to become London's top
office choir
[Music]
good evening and welcome to the program
there are calls tonight to stop two
anti-islamic campaigners from entering
Britain Robert Spencer and Pamela Geller
are wellknown
controversial views on Islam both are du
to join an event in woit next week
organized by the English Defense League
but the chair of an influential
Committee of MPS says their presence at
the site of Lee Rigby's murder would
incite hatred Keith V MP has asked the
government to ban the pair from coming
here well we'll be speaking to the head
of the edl in a moment but first here's
Nick beak I am smeared with oh but you
you know you're an edl supporter as if
it's a bad thing she is the Firebrand
American commentator who has joined
forces with the English Defense League
sharing the stage with its leader Tommy
Robinson in New York on September the
11th last year speaking out against what
they call the spread of Islam that is
the Fort that we are fighting against he
wrote the best seller the politically
incorrect guide to Islam and founded a
website called Jihad watch supporters
say they tell it like it is critics say
both demonize Muslims and shouldn't be
allowed into the UK to speak at an edl
march to woit it will take away police
resources as a critical time in the
summer when they've got a lot of other
things to do and it will give the oxygen
of publicity to two people whose views
many people file a horren the edl is
planning a rally for a week Saturday
Armed Forces Day and is to end at the
spot where drummer Lee Rigby was killed
last month one charity which monitors
anti-islamic crimes says the two
American speakers are only coming to
spread hatred not pay their respects
they want to come on uh Armed Forces Day
and they want to go to wch that's the
worst place these people can be for the
memory of drum Lee Rigby and his family
who want peace and who want to mourn and
get on with their lives in peace to have
these individuals and the edl turn up uh
and use the instance of this poor man's
murder is appalling today we spoke to
Robert Spencer who's in America he says
he has a right to I think it's
ridiculous I oppose Jihad Terror and
stand for the freedom of speech the
freedom of conscience and the equality
of Rights of all people before the law
if that's going to incite racial hatred
then Britain is in pretty bad shape
there was no official word today on what
Teresa may thinks about these two
speakers the home office said it
wouldn't comment on individual cases but
a source made clear that the Home
Secretary would stop someone from coming
into the country if she believed their
presence here was not conducive to the
public good Theresa May has also been
urged to ban the whole rally if it does
go ahead Scotland Yard says it will have
an appropriate policing plan in place
Nick beak BBC London news